das hat es noch nicht gegeben die
gesamte nordhalbkugel der erde ist
überhitzt und jetzt bestätigt
deutschlands bekanntester klimaforscher
ja das sind die folgen des klimawandels
und das ist wirklich eine wende denn
damit waren klimaexperten bisher sehr
sehr vorsichtig und es wird immer
schlimmer
krieg zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen ja es wird immer schlimmer
eigentlich so ein satz den man als
journalist nicht verwendet aber hier
trifft er zu 100 prozent so in
deutschland ist im moment eine wahre
dürrekatastrophe im gange
die ernte gegen stark zurück und in den
nächsten wochen ist nicht mit einer
abkühlung zu rechnen und hier in
deutschland
das ist keine ausnahme die gesamte
nordhalbkugel ist überhitzt wir haben ja
darüber berichten zu den waldbränden in
schweden kamen jetzt weitere verheerende
feuersbrünste in griechenland dazu
mindestens 80 menschen starben dort in
den flammen und auch hier in deutschland
brennt es inzwischen und das sind aus
der perspektive der natur eigentlich
keine außergewöhnlichen katastrophen ist
brennt einfach wenn es heiß wird dass es
schlicht und einfach unvermeidlich und
wir sind schlecht vorbereitet hier in
westeuropa gibt es einfach zu wenig oder
keine löschflugzeuge und jetzt schlagen
auch man muss sagen endlich die
klimaforscher alarm aus der abstrakten
gefahr wurde dieses jahr eine reale die
aktuelle hitzewelle ist laut motiv
außergewöhnlich weil sie schon so lange
anhält
es bestätige sich mehr und mehr was wir
klimaforscher lange vorausgesagt haben
und zwar mit blick auf den klimawandel
in deutschland sagte der meteorologe und
professor am kieler helmholtz-zentrum
für ozeanforschung der passauer neuen
presse
damit hängt er sich erstmals sehr
konkret aus dem fenster was er bisher
bei konkreten wetterereignissen immer
vermieden hat jetzt ist der klimawandel
aber wirklich nicht mehr bei diesem
ausmaß der veränderung zu verleugnen
zitat seit beginn der messung hat sich
die durchschnittliche temperatur um 14
grad erhöht das ist mehr als im globalen
durchschnitt so latif die sommerhitze
nimmt zu wir erleben immer mehr
hitzetage mit 30 grad oder mehr zugleich
nimmt die zahl der tropennächte zu in
denen die temperatur nicht mehr unter 20
grad fällt
und jetzt wird es noch wärmer hierfür
berlin werden 36 grad und mehr erwartet
es wird einfach sehr sehr heißt das
haben wir schon in der vergangenheit ich
erinnere nur an den sommer 2003 aber
noch nie so lange und noch nie so
flächendeckend kurzfristig dass sich
diese entwicklung nicht aufhalten meint
der glieder kieler klimaforscher und
kritisiert die internationale politik
tut zu wenig steuert nicht konsequent um
der weltweite co2 ausstoß steigt immer
weiter an die erderwärmung nimmt immer
weiter zu auch die bundesregierung tue
zu wenig und wird ihrer verantwortung
nicht gerecht so habe beispielsweise die
automobilindustrie die
selbstverpflichtung zum klimaschutz und
zum schadstoffausstoß nie eingehalten
lag hier weiter diese kurzfristigen
wirtschaftlichen interessen dominieren
die langfristigen interessen der umwelt
und des landes je länger wir zögern und
nichts tun desto gefährlicher würdest
und dass es jetzt schon gefährlich wird
das ist jetzt auch schon klar 2003
dauerte die hitzewelle 14 tage sie
kostete geschätzt 70.000 menschen das
leben und verursachte einen riesigen
wirtschaftlichen schaden von
wahrscheinlich mehr als zehn milliarden
euro sie war damit die opfer reiche
naturkatastrophe seit 40 jahren eine der
schwersten naturkatastrophen in europa
seit 100 jahren und das tödlichste
wetterereignis überhaupt in der
geschichte der menschheit von dem wir
zuverlässig wissen
dieses jahr wird es wohl stimmen wenn er
kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich
bei whatsapp dann umgeht er naja die
leicht unzuverlässige abo box hier auf
youtube und ihr verpasst kann wie du
mehr
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch mein schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
stimmblöcke vergessen und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
klimawandel bestätigt skeptiker
endgültig widerlegt bis dann bleibt dran